>>> JOINING US, FORMER EUROPEAN
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL AND
RETIRED U.S. ARMY COLONEL ALEX
VINDMAN.
AND FORMER AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE
BILL TAYLOR.
I WANT TO START WITH WHAT WE
JUST HEARD FROM SERGII
LESHCHENKO.
THESE STRIKES ALL ACROSS UKRAINE
TODAY, DO YOU SEE THAT AS A SIGN
OF WEAKNESS?
>> IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
IT'S A SIGN THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
KNOWS HE'S DESPERATE, KNOWS HE'S
LOSING ON THE GROUND, HE KNOWS
HIS ALLIES ARE GOING AWAY FROM
HIM, BOTH DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY.
HE CAN'T DO THINGS ON THE
GROUND.
ALL HE CAN DO IS FIRE THESE
MISSILES.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK AS YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS?
IS IT AN INFLECTION POINT AS YOU
HEARD SERGEII SAY IT IS?
>> HE HAD TO RESPOND SOMEHOW TO
THIS COMPLETELY JUSTIFIED
UKRAINIAN ATTACK ON RUSSIAN
MILITARY INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT'S WHAT THE BRIDGE IS, BUILT
WELL AFTER THE ANNEXATION OF
CRIMEA, TO FEED THE MILITARY
BEAST IN CRIMEA.
FRANKLY TO POSTURE THIS
LARGE-SCALE WAR THAT UNFOLDED
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
HE WAS GOING TO DO THIS -- THESE
TARGETS WE SAW BEING INSTRUMENT
ARE TWO CATEGORIES.
ONE IS MORALE TARGETS.
THAT GLASS BRIDGE IS A BEAUTIFUL
BRIDGE THAT OVERWATCHES THE
RIVER.
THE OTHER TARGET NEXT TO THE
PLAYGROUND, NEXT TO THE
UNIVERSITY, IT'S MAYBE 20, 30
METERS AWAY FROM WHERE I LIVED
WHEN I WAS ASSIGNED TO THE
EMBASSY.
THESE ARE NOT MILITARY TARGETS.
THERE'S ALSO HE WAS TELEGRAPHING
THIS IS WHERE HE'S GOING TO GO
AS WE GET INTO THE WINTER,
TRYING TO FORCE THE UKRAINIAN
POPULATION TO COMPROMISE, TO
GIVE UP TERRITORY BY GOING AFTER
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE, THESE
CENTRAL HUBS THAT FEED THE
ENERGY FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY WE
HAVE IT HERE.
WE HAVE ONE THERMAL PLANT THAT
MIGHT FEED HALF A CITY AS
OPPOSED TO INDIVIDUAL HEATING.
HE'S GOING TO GO AFTER THESE
THINGS JUST TO MAKE LIFE
MISERABLE.
OUR ROLE IS, AS ALLIES AND
PARTNERS, IS TO PROVIDE UKRAINE
THE AIR DEFINANCE AND POINT
DEFENSE SYSTEMS THAT THEY CAN
HARDEN THESE TARGETS WITH.
THIS IS NOT A HARD TASK.
SOME OF THESE ARE GOING IN.
THERE'S MUCH MORE WE CAN DO WITH
REGARD TO CAPTURING THESE
IRANIAN DRONES.
THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD BE GOING
TO NEXT WITH SUPPORT.
>> AMBASSADOR, DOES ANYTHING
CLIMATE CHANGE IN TERMS OF THEIR
REQUEST FOR WEAPONS?
DOES THIS MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
SOME OF THESE BIGGER SYSTEMS
THEY'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
REPEATEDLY?
>> I THINK IT INCREASES THE
DETERMINATION OF THE UKRAINIANS
TO WIN THIS WAR.
IT MAKES THEM ANGRY.
THEY'RE ENRAGED.
WE TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE AND THIS IS THE RESPONSE
OF THE UKRAINIANS.
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN THIS WAR,
AND THEY NEED THE WEAPONS.
THEY NEED THE WEAPONS.
THEY NEED THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
THIS IS JUST A FURTHER
DEMONSTRATION.
THEY'VE NEEDED THESE BEFORE.
THEY'VE ASKED FOR THEM BEFORE.
WE'RE STARTING TO PROVIDE THEM.
THEY NEED TO COME MORE QUICKLY.
THAT'S THERE.
GOING BACK TO THIS QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT IS PUTIN DOING, ALL
HE CAN DO IS FIRE THESE WEAPONS.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE SOLDIERS.
SO THE UKRAINIANS NOW NEED ALSO
THE ARMOR ON THE BATTLEFIELD TO
PUSH THEM OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
THE UKRAINIANS NEED TO PUSH THE
RUSSIANS OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
>> NOT TO MINIMIZE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING BY ANY STRETCH.
RUSH HOUR IN KYIV, PLAYGROUNDS,
YES INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETS, BUT
CIVILIAN TARGETS.
AT THE SAME TIME WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE DAMAGE THAT IS BEING
DONE, IT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
TURNS THE TIDE WHICH SPEAKS TO
WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN CAN OR
CANNOT DO.
TO WHAT END?
THERE IS NO STRATEGIC END TO
WHAT WE'RE WATCHING.
>> ALL IT IS IS A TERROR
CAMPAIGN.
BOTH BILL AND I HAVE BEEN ON THE
GROUND IN KYIV AND UKRAINE SINCE
THIS WAR STARTED.
RUSSIA REALLY IS A ONE-TRICK
PONY.
IT CAN'T DO ANYTHING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
IT'S GETTING DEFEATED AT EVERY
TURN.
THE PRESSURE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO REALLY WEIGH DOWN ON
THE KHERSON AND EASTERN
CAMPAIGNS.
THERE MAY BE ANOTHER ATTACK
THROUGH THE CENTER THROUGH
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO IS NOT
ON THE MILITARY BATTLEFIELD, BUT
TERRORIZE THE POPULATION, MAKE
IT A MISSES RABBLE WINTER FOR
THE POPULATION.
HE HAS A DWINDLING SUPPLY OF
CRUISE MISSILES.
HE HAS THE DRONES, THOSE ARE
MUCH EASIER TO DEFEAT.
THE CRUISE MISSILES FLY FASTER,
HAVE A DIFFERENT PROFILE TO
DEFEAT.
FOR THESE OTHER DRONES THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE PROVIDING,
THEY'RE SLOW.
YOU NEED DEFENSE AROUND THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, CITY
CENTERS, THERMAL PLANTS.
WE JUST NEED TO SATURATE THE
ENVIRONMENT THERE AND THIS COULD
EASILY REDUCE THE PRESSURE THAT
RUSSIA IS PUTTING ON UKRAINE AND
MAKE THIS A MUCH, MUCH MORE
BEARABLE CAMPAIGN AS THE
MILITARY CAMPAIGN THAT'S FAR
MORE DECISIVE TURNS AND ENDS
PUTIN'S -- ENDS HIS ASPIRATIONS
FOR THIS WAR.
>> IT'S CLEAR HE IS TRYING TO
RAMP UP THINGS FOR NOW.
BUT HOW EFFECTIVE IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
UKRAINE IS DOING EXTREMELY WELL.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL ALEXANDER
VINDMAN, AMBASSADOR BILL TAYLOR,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>>> FOR MORE ON THE OVERNIGHT
BLASTS LET'S BRING IN RETIRED
BRIGADIER GENERAL STEVEN
ANDERSON.
YOUR BACKGROUND IS IN LOGISTICS.
I WANT TO START WITH WHAT
PROMPTED THE MISSILE STRIKES
WHICH IS THIS BRIDGE OVER THE
STRAIT THAT WAS STRUCK,
PARTIALLY COLLAPSED MAYBE
DETERIORATING SOME OF THE RAIL
ABILITIES.
WHAT ARE THE LOGISTICS
CHALLENGES THAT WERE CREATED
WITH THAT THAT MAY HAVE SPURRED
SUCH A REACTION FROM VLADIMIR
PUTIN?
>> THANK YOU, BRIANNA.
THIS IS A HUGELY SIGNIFICANT
LOGISTICALLY.
THIS BRIDGE HERE GOES ACROSS THE
STRAIT.
IT'S THE ONLY BRIDGE THEY'VE GOT
THAT GOES OVER THAT WAY.
IT BRINGS RAIL, IT BRIDGES ROAD.
IT'S THE MAJOR LIFELINE FOR THE
ENTIRE CRIMEA PENINSULA.
IT'S IMPORTANT IF THEY CAN TAKE
IT OUT.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO OVERESTIMATE
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO REBUILD THE
BRIDGE.
I THINK THEY ALREADY REBUILT THE
RAIL.
BUT I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY IS
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF
THIS.
IT MIGHT NOT BE AT THE LEVEL
WHERE THE SHIP SINKING WAS
MONTHS AGO BUT THIS SENDS A
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD, THE
RUSSIANS, THAT THEY ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT TAKING BACK CRIMEA, THE
UKRAINIANS, AND THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTACK A KEY
TARGET LIKE THIS BRIDGE.
>> IT FEELS LIKE IT'S IN THE
SAME VEIN AS THE SHIP TAKEDOWN.
HE'S HITTING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETS, WHAT'S
THAT MEAN FOR UKRAINE?
>> HE'S SHARPENING HIS FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT.
HE'S BEEN GOOD AT INDISCRIMINATE
ATTACKS.
I'VE SEEN THE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN KNOCKED
OUT WHEN I WAS THERE.
HIS ATTACKS HAVE BEEN MOSTLY
TARGETS YOU AND I CAN PICK UP ON
GOOGLE EARTH.
BUT NOW AT LEAST HE'S STARTING
TO GO AFTER THE LOGISTICS
INFRASTRUCTURE, THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND THAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS A MAJOR RESPONSE TO THE
KERCH BRIDGE.
HE'S TRYING TO PLACATE THE HARD
LINERS HE'S SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH.
AND HE WANTS TO ATTACK IN A BIG
WAY AND, OF COURSE, THIS IS THE
BIGGEST ATTACK I THINK WE'VE HAD
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
WILL OF UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WILL
NOT BE DETERRED AT ALL.
THEIR RESOLVE WILL BE STEELED
AND THEY'LL CONTINUE TO FIGHT
BACK.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
ABOUT THIS, THIS IS HIS ONLY
PLAY, OTHER THAN THE NUCLEAR
OPTION.
HIS ONLY CONVENTIONAL CAPABILITY
ARE THE CRUISE MISSILES, LONG
RANGE MISSILES.
AND I DON'T THINK HE HAS THAT
MANY LEFT.
THIS WILL NOT CONTINUE FOR VERY
LONG.
I THINK HE DID IT AS A SHOW OF
FORCE BEFORE THE SECURITY
COUNCIL MEETING WITH HIS
MINISTERS BUT I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE BACK TO NORMAL SOON.
>> THAT MAY BE AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
TALK ABOUT THE NEW COMMANDER,
NICK PATON WALSH WAS MENTIONING
THIS.
THE NEW COMMANDER HE HAS IN
PLACE, ARE YOU SEEING A NEW
APPROACH?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S GOING
TO BE A NEW APPROACH BECAUSE
HE'S INCAPABLE OF DOING A NEW
APPROACH.
AS LONG AS THE RUSSIAN ARMY,
WHICH IS A TERRIBLE ARMY, THIS
GUY IS A HORRIBLE DEUDE, HE
SERVED IN SYRIA, HE'S BEEN
JAILED TWICE, AN INTERESTING
CHARACTER, BUT HE'S A HARD
LINER.
AGAIN, THIS IS A WAY TO APPEASE
THE HARD LINERS THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN HAS SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH.
SO HE HAS THIS GUY IN CHARGE.
BUT IT'S NOT LIKE THE SOLDIERS
ARE GOING TO JUMP INTO A PHONE
BOOTH AND COME OUT AS SUPERMAN.
THEY HAVE A TERRIBLE ARMY.
THEY'RE TEN YEARS AWAY FROM
HAVING A GOOD ARMY THAT CAN TAKE
ON THE UKRAINIANS AND ACHIEVE
THE MILITARY OBJECTIVES THEY
WANTED.
THEY HAVE A LOW MORALE.
WE'VE SEEN THE TERRIBLE ACTS OF
AWES ATY THEY'VE COMMITTED
AGAINST THE UKRAINIANS.
THEY'RE INCAPABLE OF EXECUTING
THE MILITARY OPERATIONS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTS.
GEORGE PAT TON COULDN'T MAKE
THIS A SUCCESS FOR PUTIN.
>> A GOOD POINT.
WE'VE SEEN MANY COMMANDERS TRY
AT THIS POINT.
GENERAL ANDERSON, THANK YOU.